climate proposes 1 story
they tell us that 97
percent of scientists agree what
is pertinent nonsense
alone
how do you get those other scientists to speak
when they speak out and they work at university
then they lose their jobs
but in the end
it is 1 very very fundamental
something where we've just seen the government
actively involved in driving narrative
1 narrative about immigration
about climate about Ukraine
about Corona name it all on LGBT
LGBT is 1 very good example
all those things
so if
we do not protect the free internet and the free
exchange of ideas
we lose everything
and I think very few people realize that
how awful
fundamentally this is